hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
recidivism recidivism recidivating I
can't damn it
recidivism oh there was a safe right
here I guess I could have you know
waited from the last episode to this one
alright now finally oh wait this is
nothing but a save new key nothing
really
this is a safe room I don't feel very
safe in this room ok so uh I was
wondering when reality would begin to
unravel oh the door won't budge thank
you very much it sounded like a key
alright so at least there's not that
whatnot I wait a minute the doors have
all oh that's where a reality unraveled
Oh lovely oh this is jolly good oh boy
why God oh my ha
Sophie is that you so V so babe don't
make me blow your head off
Sophie if that's really you then show me
your boobs do it
alright ok ah doing that so BAE BAE got
there Oh what oh I've already seen it
I got [ __ ] Oh No all right Laurie kill
myself so we how oh no oh no oh no oh
wait oh ok ha ha ok all right
Nico save now you go save in the shed
now I can get through the door good good
oh this is gray my baby and I turn the
power off cuz I'm a douche that probably
turned the power off to that keypad but
also unleash the monster from hell Oh
monsters from hell I'm really god damn
it
ok hang on I got a nail him in the
header it boom there we go
those guys need to be taken out with the
headshot ah good malls but they hurt
like a son of a [ __ ] if they actually
hit me
so anybody there
crouched like wow
okay at least they give me ammo ah what
dot what the hell what the heck II hack
huh
did I come this way I don't even
remember I got it thank you get a
headshot thank you
I like the plume of blood spouting every
which way was good by means I'm a psycho
if I like that it's a good psycho see
the demons get their just desserts
or something like that I don't really
know dark dark slowly get like I don't
like that I don't like that at all the
light it's not on it oh come on not the
invisi non-invisible bars to close this
whose blood is this
for security storage huh it won't budge
now that's fantastic bleep it up
come out come out wherever you are
markiplier is here to play oh good I
played a game called jump down the hump
jump down as many stairs as you can
what's up what that wasn't there
I look good what what what I'm so
confused
baby what's there
okay I quit all right no I'll keep going
cuz I'm so brave
I'm so pretty come on oh not water not
water not water no water let's say this
is what's this can i bond kit can i bunk
it no I do it with my fists
I'm a badass oh yeah no no okay the bunk
- I miss Wang it's hard to miss the
floor but I managed to do it huh hey I
know that weird tentacle crap
do I need to punch it with my fist and
wait
got your get gun down oh oh oh dude you
know who you can do hook up a job no ok
so that's definitely a no-go
ok so what was the point of all this
seriously I would like enough no one
this way oh there's a door here when is
there a door the out of the door well
but anyway maybe there was a door over
there that I miss
no nothing seriously what was it that's
the point of all this is it air duct I
can't seem to go through it huh let me
through
yeah you're all slimy and technically oh
I know where this is going I know the
price I need to pay to you through that
Luba is not gonna be fun alright okay
I'm actually confused because I I don't
know what what I'm supposed to do
cuz that way is like totally blocked off
huh what what what's going on no no no
no there's got to be a way down there's
got to be something there that I'm
missing that's the way it usually is I'm
an idiot until proven otherwise
so here we go show me Mr compliance the
puzzle solving master world's greatest
detective is there something in the
water like I have an IQ of potato
oh nothing in the water that I can see
all right
I'm gonna try something radical here
maybe I'll just shoot this blam
no ah
March oh good maybe I'm supposed to
shoot that slimy goop
laughs no damn it
what am I supposed to do now those I
shoot this panel or maybe I'm stressed
out Beefaroni this panel up huh tell me
your secrets tell me our secret aah aah
all right so um oh this is good
always good sign when I get lost I'll
figure it out don't worry what she here
maybe I should accelerate into the
future like I usually do future self I'm
calling you this is future market Blair
I went back here and I saw something
there was something there I didn't solve
the puzzle so I thought maybe I crack
crack a bit we're doing something there
I saw something it looked weird it was
freaky and had a long leg
we freaky-looking what that wait a
minute
was this where I was oh no yes it was
never on I saw something back here I
swear
i swears it I did I did I saw something
I'm sorry to bring your attention back
to the game but I thought it was
important I died when you Morton Oh No
there's nothing here is there I saw
something didn't sit but I saw I saw it
I swear I'm not going crazy you're crazy
don't call me crazy I'm not crazy
those the thing none of me come on 1101
here I saw it you believe me now I'm not
crazy
come on
I hate letters numb Jim yeah all right
oh I'm up here now can I get over there
I'm not even try cuz I'll probably fall
off and kill myself and I haven't saved
him like forever oh good god is the
kitchen but oh man this is taking on a
whole new level of strange oh I do not
know
oh my what does an obvious trap ah those
are that don't do that don't do that
No Oh AHA oh good god no it's freaky oh
yeah I'm gonna take that syringe that
that dead pushing guy was using ah Oh
God
oh yeah walls covered in blood always a
good thing today any more traps man
whoever made this is good
cleaver it's too su day uses a weapon hi
nothing is too rusty to use as a weapon
silly Billy
hello okay so I got the cleaver what am
I supposed to do with the cleaver like
leave some meat I don't like that gong
and booby gorgon booby Gong in you be
gone
no you be gone it you tell me if you
were gong in right out there all right I
get back it won't move at all now that's
okay I'm just gonna get out of here man
whoever made this custom campaign I
think it's EC I thought I saw nice
landscape is that the ocean name tell I
wish you could stand on one of these
chairs where they seem to be preoccupied
with something I still don't know where
that thing I saw went I can't get over
there can I it'd be it'd be foolish to
try that I'm a fool Oh
my foolish flags are now broken what a
fool I was I brought dishonor to my
family okay all right I have a meat
cleaver what am I supposed to do with it
seriously what what is it boy what could
there possibly be for the meat cleaver
to be Oh the tentacles
oh that makes so much sense I should go
there
I need to save I haven't saved in like
forever if I die it would be
catastrophic cata stayed you before
hold on thank you they're hitting your
soft underbelly okay
you're a newly modeled woman scream
lady screamer didn't move so you mean
you're not very threatening haha
that was a guy god you're stupider than
women right right ladies yeah that's
what I thought yeah yeah totally true
you know guys you're dumb
I trust this a lot less now okay here we
go
use no I said come on be correct
what the what did use it ahaha they
didn't even show the action happening on
that good okay I'm all out of time for
this episode so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and dragging -
totally not dragging timeout and do it
and always Oh see you in the next video
bye bye